[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
SARAH HEWETT: All right.
Good afternoon.
Today, we are going
to start talking
about a new lab, the
Essential Oil lab.
And if we look ahead a
little bit in the semester,
so we're still working on
finishing up the Charles River
lab.
We have today, then we have day
four on Wednesday and Thursday.
And then next Monday
and Tuesday will
be day five of the
Charles River lab,
and that'll be your quiz day.
And then after that,
we're going to start
a whole new set of labs.
And the last three
labs of the semester--
so there are five total labs--
we're going to rotate so not
everybody is going to be doing
the same lab at the same time.
So each bay in each
group with your TA,
you'll be doing a different lab.
So everybody will get a
chance to do all three,
but you'll just do them
in a different order.
So after the Charles River
lab, the A prime 2 group,
the closest to the
middle of the lab,
you'll be doing the
essential oil lab.
The center group will be
doing the catalase lab,
and then the group closest
to the doors, A prime 4,
will be doing the ester lab.
And your TAs will help
make sure that which
lab you're supposed to do so you
know which pre-lab to write up.
And if you any questions,
it corresponds to groups
A, B, and C in the printed
version of the lab manual,
and I think the
version on Steller
has been corrected with
the A prime notation
for telling you which lab you're
going to be doing when so you
can keep track of
what you need to write
and what pre-labs
you need to do.
And then if we take a
moment and look back
a little bit at what we
did for the Charles River,
I went on to the EPA
website, and they
have a buoy outside the
Museum of Science just down
the river a little
ways where they
keep track of a whole bunch of
different metrics in the water.
And you can go check out
what the buoy has recorded.
And so if you're interested,
you can go to this website.
And they have, also, the
Massachusetts standards
that you can compare these
numbers to for some of them
anyway.
And so the most recent
reading that they had
was from Monday, September
23, which was last week.
And you can see that the pH
was around eight and a half
which is similar to
what you guys measured.
The dissolved oxygen that they
had was around 10 and 1/2,
which is a little bit higher
than what you guys had,
but again, it
changes we know based
on the temperature and the day.
And then this pink line that I
added down here at the bottom
is the phycocyanin which is
indicative of the cyanobacteria
that you heard about
in lecture before.
And so you can see
it was it peaked here
in July and the
beginning of August
when we had the
cyanobacteria bloom.
So something that
you can check out
if you want to when
you're writing up your lab
report if you want some more
information about what metrics
they look at and keep track
of in the Charles River.
And now, talking about our
next lab, essential oils.
So the word essential has
a few different definitions
depending on how
you're using it.
And some people will say
it's essential, like, it's
the most important thing.
The definition of
essential that we
mean when we are talking
about an essential oil
is that it is a
fundamental or central
to the nature of
something or someone,
like the essence of a thing.
And so the essential oils
come from plants, typically.
And so we are talking
about the essence
of the plant or something
that comes from that plant
specifically.
A little bit of history
of essential oils.
Their recorded use is far back
in history as ancient Egypt.
The Egyptians were big into
perfumes and cosmetics and all
of that.
And they have records
of pressing plants
to get the oils out to
use in different perfumes
for the different scents.
And also, in the days of the
plague in the medieval era,
the doctors would wear these
masks full of different plants.
And they thought that breathing
through the plants and the oils
would help protect
them from disease.
And if you look around
now at essential oils,
you can find them
almost anywhere.
But you may come
across something
called thieves' oil, which
is a blend of the oils
from those different plants.
And the story behind that, which
may or may not be a legend,
is that there during
the plague, everybody
would throw all their
corpses out into the street
and then there
would be people who
would go and loot the corpses
to steal what they could.
And there was a
group of thieves who
was running around
stealing stuff off
of all these dead bodies
but they never got sick.
And rumor has it that
they concocted this oil,
and they would wear that
and put that on themselves
and it prevented the plague.
And so that's what the
story of the thieves' oil
may or may not be true.
So today, if you
look online and you
do a search for
essential oils, you
can find a million different
places to buy them.
You can find all
sorts of information,
some true some not, about
what essential oils do.
So you may see
something like this
that has different
types of essential oils,
different plants that they come
from, and all of the things
that they are rumored to treat.
You can buy the essential oil of
almost any plant that you like,
depending on where you look.
And not all of this
is just hearsay.
There are people
that are actually
doing different
studies, especially
in the veterinary
medicine world, of using
different essential
oils to treat
different fungal infections
or bacterial infections.
A lot of these have
antibiotic properties,
and they can disrupt
some biofilms
depending on the
different properties which
isn't super surprising
since a lot of these
are just hydrocarbons that
you could also synthesize
and are similar in
structure to some
of the drugs and
synthetic products
that we make to do
these same things.
So essential oils,
where do they come from?
So you ... how do you go from
something that looks like
a plant from the garden
to a little vial of oil?
And the ratio of
how much plant you
need to get a few milliliters
of oil is very, very large.
So it's not the most
efficient process.
But the way that it is most
commonly done commercially now
is through steam distillation.
So you can grind up
your plant material,
chop it up a little bit to
increase the surface area.
You heat up water, put
steam through the material.
It helps volatilize the oils.
And then the steam and
the oils co-distill.
You can condense it back down.
And then you'll get a
mixture of this water
with all of the water
soluble parts of the plant
and then your essential oils,
and you can separate them out.
And the reason that you
can separate them out
is due to their structure.
So most essential oils are
made up of isoprene units.
And so that's the
structure of an isoprene.
It has five carbons
and eight hydrogens.
And then when you
stick them together,
you get a class of
molecules called terpenes.
And so a terpene is more
than one isoprene unit.
So the way that you
name these things
is that if you have
two isoprene units,
that's the smallest
terpene you can have,
so it's called the monoterpene.
Then sesquiterpene,
diterpene is four
because it has two
of the monoterpenes.
Triterpene and tetraterpene
is when you have eight.
So if we look at
some of the molecules
that you may know
from everyday life,
does anyone know what this is?
So that's vitamin A. If you
look at the structure of it,
we can try and find all
of the isoprene units, so
these five carbon units.
So if you start at the
top there is one there.
And we have another one,
two, three, four, five there.
And then you can keep
going down the chain.
So how many isoprene
units do we have here?
We have one, two, three, four.
So this would be a diterpene.
And then does anyone know
what this molecule is?
So that's menthol use
in minty flavorings.
And this has two isoprene units
and then this hydroxy group.
So you can have these
terpene structures that
have the isoprene units
and then they also
can have different
functional groups attached.
A lot of times it'll
be a hydroxyl group
or a carbonyl group.
And then this molecule, which
you also may have heard of,
is camphor.
So that's used in lotions a lot
of times to treat irritation.
And this one's a
little bit tricky,
but you can find
the isoprene unit.
So there's one there
and then one there.
Oh, other way.
So those are some
common terpenes
that are found in essential
oils that you may or may not
have seen in other contexts.
The structure that
we care about,
in this particular
lab-- yes, Jesse.
STUDENT: I'm a
little bit confused.
So on the slide said five
carbon and eight hydrogens?
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
STUDENT: So for menthol, for
instance, there's five carbons
and more than eight hydrogens.
Right?
SARAH HEWETT: Yes, in
this case they would.
STUDENT: So does it require
a double bond in order for it
to be called-- classified
as an isoprene?
SARAH HEWETT: No.
I was also kind of
curious about that,
and I personally didn't find
a good answer on the internet.
But when I was looking through
the literature and stuff,
menthol was referred
to as a terpene.
So I don't know,
if maybe once they
get combined together
with the double bonds
that it's not as strict, or once
you start adding extra groups.
I'm not sure.
That's a good question, and
I can get back to you on that
and how they actually name
and classify these things.
Because, yeah, in
some of the cases,
the double bonds go
away, and it doesn't
have quite the right ratio.
So in our lab, the
essential oil component
that we are going to be
looking at is carvone.
And there are two
types of carvone.
So carvone is a major
component of spearmint oil
and is also a major
component of carraway oil.
And those are two
very different things,
and if you've smelled
either of them, then
that they smell different,
they taste different.
And the reason for that is
because we have a chiral center
down at the bottom.
So there are two
different possible isomers
of this molecule and they
have different properties,
some properties are different.
So we'll need to take a moment
and look at chiral centers.
So a chiral center occurs when
four different substituents are
attached to one carbon center.
And you have probably
talked about this
in your organic chemistry class
or in your other chemistry
courses.
So as a quick
refresher to determine,
they are labeled the R
versus S. And to determine
whether it's an R or an S
stereocenter, you go through
and you look at each group
that's attached to the carbon,
and then you assign
priority to each group.
And this is typically
done most straightforward
is through atomic mass.
So you look at
the atoms that are
attached to the carbon center.
And then the highest atomic
mass has the highest priority.
The lowest has the
lowest priority.
And if you have
a double bond, it
counts as two bonds
the atom counts twice.
So if you have longer
chains and they look similar
at the first point, then you
keep going down the chain
until the first
point of difference
and then you can
help assign priority.
So if we look at our
carvone molecule,
usually, if your
stereocenter has a hydrogen,
that's pretty much always going
to be your lowest priority
group.
So I've drawn this
particular isomer
with the hydrogen
pointing away from us
so that we can more easily
determine R versus S. So
can anyone help assign the
priority of these three groups?
Does anyone know what the
highest priority would be?
Alec.
STUDENT: It would be the
substituent towards the end.
SARAH HEWETT: Yep.
Why?
STUDENT: Because it's attached
to a carbon that is secondary.
It's attached to
two more carbons.
SARAH HEWETT: Yes.
STUDENT: And a double bond.
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah, no,
you're saying it right.
So this one's attached
to two carbons and one
of them being a double bonds
so that counts kind of twice.
And these carbons are just
attached to two hydrogens each,
so this has an overall
higher atomic mass,
so this is going to be
our highest priority.
Then what?
Pointing out this way.
So then you go to this carbon,
and this one's double bonded
to a carbon.
But this one's double
bonded to an oxygen
so that has higher
priority and that
just leaves our final group.
So does this go
counterclockwise or clockwise?
Counterclockwise?
So R or S?
S.
So the way that
chiral molecules work
is if you take the
mirror image, then you
get the opposite configuration.
So if this is our S, if we
flip these two substituents
on our chiral center,
then we get the R.
Or if you prefer to look at
it as the actual mirror image,
if you kind of ignore this, then
this molecule and this molecule
are the mirror
image of each other.
So even though this group
is pointing forward in both,
the oxygen and the double
bond have flip sides,
so these two are mirror images.
So this is also R.
And a big part of
organic chemistry
and figuring these
things out is being
able to manipulate the molecules
spatially in your head.
A lot of times it's
easier with models.
But does that makes
sense how we get those?
Excellent.
So we can talk about
different cultural centers,
and we can also talk
about chiral molecules
as a quick review.
So if you have chiral
centers in your molecule,
then you'll have, potentially,
a chiral molecule.
So a molecule's
chiral if it is not
superimposable on
its mirror image.
And then within that,
we have two other ways
to name these stereoisomers.
One is in enantiomer which
is a pair of molecules
that are mirror
images that are not
superimposable on each other.
So that would be like
this pair of molecules.
So these are enantiomers.
They are mirror images.
And if you try to flip
this around and stick it
on this one, you'll see
that if you flip this over
so that the chlorine
and the hydroxyl group
are on the same side,
they'll be pointing back
and these are not
superimposable.
Same thing with these two.
These are enantiomers.
They are mirror images,
and they are not
superimposable on each other.
But you can see that all four
of these molecules are related
and that they are
isomers and that they
have the same atoms in a
very similar configuration.
The only thing that differs
is the stereochemistry
at each of these chiral centers.
And so these molecules, say,
are related to each other
and that they are
not mirror images,
but they are also not
superimposable on each other.
And so these are called
diastole diastereomers.
These two have the
same relationship.
These are diastereomers.
So are these two and these two.
So that's the
terminology that we
are going to be
using when we talk
about different
molecules that have
different numbers
of chiral centers.
So if you have more
than one chiral center,
you can get all of these
different relationships.
This becomes important
in biological systems.
So if you have a protein, your
amino acids in your protein
are chiral.
So you end up with
protein the protein
structure is determined by the
chirality of these amino acids.
So you can end up
with a chiral surface
that has a bunch of chiral and
individual molecules in it.
And then if you have a
substrate for your enzyme
that is also chiral and you
have different enantiomers,
one will fit and one will not.
And you can also look at it if
you have a cultural center that
has three different things
to it and a receptor that
has three different
locations, then
there is only one orientation
that will match up properly.
So if you start rearranging
those substituents
around that carbon
center, then you
won't be able to line up
with your target properly.
And this comes into play in
your eyes and in your smell
and in your taste.
So these carvone isomers,
these enantiomers,
one of them taste like mint
and the other one tastes like
carraway .
And most people can
tell the difference.
There is about 10% of the
population that cannot tell
the difference between
these two isomers.
So when you get your oil
in lab, if you smell yours
and then if you smell your
neighbor's, hopefully you
should be able to
smell a difference.
But it'll be interesting to see
if anybody can or cannot tell
the difference between
these two chemicals.
One of the ways that this chiral
recognition and this chirality
in biology has played out is in
the case of thalidomide, which
again, is something
that you may have
heard of in your other
chemistry courses.
So this is the structure
of thalidomide.
And there is a chiral center.
Where's the chiral
center in thalidomide?
Right there.
You be a little more specific.
To the right of the N, yes.
So here's a chiral
center, so you
can have an R and S
versions of thalidomide.
And as it turns out, let's see,
I don't want to say this wrong.
The r version is used to
treat nausea and is used
uses a sleeping aid.
And the S version
causes birth defects.
And so this drug was
given in the '70s
and the '80s to a lot of women
who had morning sickness.
And they took it while
they were pregnant
and their children ended up
with a lot of birth defects
because they were given both
enantiomers of this drug.
And even if they had been
given enantiomerically pure
thalidomide, your
body has enzymes
and you can do reactions
that will convert in
between the stereoisomers.
So there is no safe
way to give thalidomide
to a pregnant woman.
In a less traumatic
case, ibuprofen,
this is the structure
of ibuprofen.
Where's our chiral center?
STUDENT: That one.
SARAH HEWETT: That one?
Excellent.
So you can have R and S
versions of ibuprofen as well,
and only the S version of
this drug works in your body
as a pain reliever.
And it inhibits certain
chemical reactions
in that pathway in your body.
And biology majors, I'm sure
you know way more about this
than I do.
So the S version
works in the R version
has no biological
activity, at least in terms
of the target of
this drug, which is
to treat pain and inflammation.
But it's given as
a racemic mixture
because the second
enantiomer does not
have any negative effects
that we know about.
And your body can actually
convert between the two.
So if you're given
all of the S form,
which they have done
to people and that
actually has more of
a benefit to them,
but it'll convert
some of it into the R
form which is useless anyway.
So if we go back to
our molecule carvone,
we can look at the
two types of carvone.
And these are the
two isomers, so they
have the same molecular
weight, same boiling point
but different physical
property in how they smell
and how they taste.
So carvone is what
we care about,
but essential oils are
not pure substances.
So if we give you
the spearmint oil
and we give you
the carraway oil,
then they'll have more in
it than just the carvone
that we care about.
So the major impurity
that you guys
are going to see in both
of these essential oils
is called limonene.
And that is the
structure of limonene.
It is also chiral.
So it has a chiral center
down here at the bottom.
And-- oh, my notes
didn't show up.
Bummer.
And so one of the
isomers of this,
I believe it's the R
smells like oranges
and the S smells like lemons.
So it's found in high
quantities in citrus plants.
It's a monoterpene.
It has two of these
isoprene units.
And in our case, it's
going to be an impurity.
So we are going to
try and separate
the carvone in our essential
oil from the limonene
in our essential oil.
So if we look at these two
compounds side by side,
how are we going
to separate them?
Alec.
STUDENT: Carvone has
an oxygen so we're
going to pull it in limonene?
SARAH HEWETT: Yeah.
So one way you could
think about separating
these is by they are very
similar in structure,
but the only major
difference here
is this oxygen, which makes the
carvone slightly more polar.
So you could think
about using some sort
of chromatographic
technique, maybe,
like we did before to separate
them based on polarity.
So that's one way
we could do it.
What else is
different about them?
STUDENT: Boiling point.
SARAH HEWETT: The boiling point.
And so using the polarity is
a little bit more complicated.
But if we want to use
straightforward basic gen chem
principles, then we
can separate them
by our boiling point
using distillation
which is a technique that
you all probably heard of.
And I have the distillation
apparatus set up here.
So this distillation
apparatus is a short path
simple distillation.
So the way distillation
works is if you have either
a mixture of two liquids that
have different boiling points
or if you have a liquid that
has some nonvolatile impurities
in it, you can put
your mixture in here,
heat it up, and then
re condense the vapor
and then you can
collect, hopefully,
your purified substance
at the end of it.
So if we have this
mixture of two liquids,
then we need to talk
about different laws that
govern how two liquids
and how to vapors interact
with each other.
So the first thing that we want
to talk about is Raoult's law.
And what Raoult's law says
is that the partial pressure
of a substance is equal
to the mole fraction
of that substance, which
is the x, times the vapor
pressure of the pure substance.
So if we have a
mixture of two things,
and we want to figure out
what the vapor pressure of one
of them is above
the mixture, and we
look at the mole fraction
within the mixture.
And the mole fraction is just
the moles of the component
that we care about over the
total moles in your mixture.
So if you have two
things, you add
to the total number
of moles, divide that
by the number of moles of the
thing that you care about.
And then you can look
up the vapor pressure
of what the pure
substance would be,
and then you can get the vapor
pressure of that substance
above a mixture.
And then Dalton's law
of partial pressure
says that the total
pressure of a gas
is going to be equal to the
sum of the partial pressures.
So if you can figure out
your partial pressures
using Raoult's law, then if
you have a mixture of pentane
and hexane-- and this was
taken from your textbook
if you want to look this up.
If you read this,
it's in figure 12.3.
Chapter 12 is all
about distillation.
So that's a good resource
for this lab in particular.
But if you have pure pentane,
then your total pressure
is going to be just the
pressure of pentane.
And this is your
And then you can see that if
you add up these two lines, then
you'll get the total equaling
your blue line, which
is your total pressure
at various different mole
fractions of each
of these substances.
So the way that it
plays out for us,
if we're going to be heating
up a mixture and at--
hello-- and a different
mole fractions, then we'll
have different amounts of
each vapor in our total vapor
pressure, then we need
to think about that when
we are doing our distillation.
And so you can make a
temperature composition
diagram.
And this is a little bit
confusing to look at it first,
or at least it was for me.
So we can go through how
this plays out in real life.
So if you have a mixture
of hexane and pentane--
this is just a
theoretical situation.
And the boiling points of hexane
are 68 degrees and pentane
boils at 36 degrees.
And we wanted to get pure
pentane which is our lower
boiling point thing.
So if we start out with a
mixture that's about 75% hexane
and we vaporize it, then the
boiling point of that liquid
will be closer to the
boiling point of hexane
because there's
more hexane in it.
If we cool that vapor down so
it's at the same temperature,
so heat it up to 65,
cool it to a vapor at 65,
and then re-condense
it to a liquid phase,
now our mole fraction
of hexane is about half.
So we've purified our vapor.
If we take a starting
mixture that has about half
and half hexane and
pentane and we heat that up
to its boiling
point, which is now
going to be lower because it
has a higher fraction of pentane
in it, if we cool it down
at the same temperature
and then re-condense
it to the liquid phase,
now our mixture has about
a little less than 0.4
of our more fraction of hexane.
And then if we heat that
back up and vaporize it,
cool it back down, now
we have even less hexane.
Heat it up, cool
it down, now we are
getting very close to pure
pentane with no hexane in it.
So we get very close to a mole
fraction of zero for a hexane,
and we get closer to the actual
boiling point of pure pentane.
So if you look at
this diagram, then how
many of those
heating and cooling
and re-vaporization
cycles did we
have to go through to
get down to a vapor that
is pure in pentane?
So in this case, it's
about five cycles of that.
And depending on the difference
in boiling point of your two
liquids that you're
trying to separate,
it may take even more cycles
to get to your pure compound
that you care about.
And if the boiling points
are greater in difference,
then it'll take fewer cycles to
get to your pure liquid phase.
So if we have these two liquids
that we were trying to separate
and we want to get down to
a pure fractions of limonene
in carvone and we want
to separate them and make
them pure, how are
we going to do that?
A lot of distillations.
Or we can do what's called
a fractional distillation.
So I told you this before.
This one is a
simple distillation,
and you can see that there
is not a lot of room in here
for the vapor to vaporize
and then re-condense
before you collect it in your
collection vessels over here.
If you provide
more surface area,
then the vapor has more
chances to come into contact
with the cooler glass.
It'll re-condense
into the liquid phase.
And then if you're heating
this, it'll drip down,
it'll be reheated by
the hot vapor coming up,
and so then you can have
multiple of these heating
and cooling cycles
before you start
collecting your final product.
And so this is a fractionating
column or a Vigreux column.
And you can see,
hopefully maybe,
that it is not just
straight glass, that it
has all of these
little divots in it
and it has a lot
of kind of spikes
going into the middle that
provide a lot of surface area
for this vapor to hit
to cool and to reheat.
So this provides a much
more efficient separation
than just the simple
distillation when you can only
go through a couple of
heating and cooling cycles
before you collect it.
So this will help us to
get a more pure product.
And it is very helpful for
when the two things that you're
trying to separate have boiling
points that are relatively
close to each other,
being like less than 50
or 60 degrees apart.
So there are some
things to consider
if you're going to use
distillation as a technique
anyway.
And so one of them is the
boiling point of liquids
that you're trying to separate.
So how hot does this
thing need to get?
Is it a feasible temperature
for you to reach in the lab?
One of them is how pure
your fractions need to be.
So if you don't really
care about the purity
of your fractions, then you can
do a quick simple distillation,
collect your product,
call it a day.
And then do your
compounds decompose
if you heat them too high?
And in our case, yes, they do.
So if we heat our
compounds too high,
so they have a pretty
high boiling point
if you remember back or if
you look back in your slides.
So we try to hit
them aggressively
to that boiling point,
then our products
may decompose before
we can collect them.
So we have to figure out a way
to make things boil at a lower
temperature.
So if we think about our
definition of boiling,
it is the temperature at which
the vapor pressure of a liquid
equals the pressure
above the liquid.
So there are two
ways that if we need
to lower our boiling points
that we don't have to heat it up
to over 200 degrees, then how
do we lower the boiling point?
We can either increase the
vapor pressure of the liquid.
So usually, we increase
the pressure of the liquid
by just heating it.
You heat the molecules up,
they become into the gas phase,
and you increase the pressure
within the liquid itself.
Or you can reduce the
pressure above the solution.
So if we reduce the
pressure above the solution,
then we don't have
to heat it as much
in order for those
pressures to be equal.
So that is what we're
going to do in class.
We're going to
use both of these.
We're going to have
to heat it, and we're
going to reduce the
vapor pressure in order
to make the vapor pressure a
reasonable temperature for us
to get to in the lab.
And the way that we're
going to be doing this
is with a vacuum distillation.
So this distillation setup
is identical to the one
that you will be
setting up in the lab.
And this is kind of nice
because the glassware is all
sealed together.
So your column, your condenser,
and your distilling head
over here have all
been made as one piece
you have fewer joints where
you could lose your vacuum.
So when you get
this, you're going
to get it as a kit
from the stockroom,
and it will have this one
big piece of glassware in it,
so be very careful when
you are opening and taking
things out of this
kit because this
is a large piece of glass where
it should be wrapped in bubble
wrap in most cases, but
we don't want to break it
because it is expensive and a
specialty piece of equipment.
So if we go through this and
talk about different pieces,
they're all very important.
So this is where
your mixture will go.
And if you look at the picture
of an actual set up in lab,
you'll have your stirring plate.
So whenever you
heat something you
want to stir it so that it helps
the bubbles to form because you
don't want your solution
to get superheated
and then all start
boiling all at one time
because it'll shoot
up into your column.
And then if you flood your
column with your mixture,
then there aren't any surfaces
for the vaporization cycles
to happen, and so you will get
very inefficient separation
of your two liquids.
So you want to make sure
that you have stirring
and you don't heat it too
quickly so that you don't flood
your column with the
bubbles and that you give it
a chance to just
have the vapor go up
your fractionating column.
So you'll have your heating
mantle, your stirring plate,
and then you'll have
your mixture in here.
This is your
fractionating column.
And then you'll have
your thermometer.
And our thermometers
are all set up
to have a ground glass
joint, so they'll just
sit right in the top here.
And you want to make sure
that the thermometer bulb is
right in the path of where your
vapor is traveling so that you
can monitor the
temperature of the vapor
that you're collecting so you
know what the temperature is.
And you can use it
to help identify
which fraction is which.
So if you know the
temperature of the vapor
that you're collecting,
then you can
compare that to
the boiling point
you know what you're collecting.
Then you'll have your
condenser, and this is going
to be filled with cold water.
So we have cold water
supplies from the hood.
You will attach the water in at
the bottom and out at the top.
Your TAs will go over this,
too, but this is very important
because you want this whole
thing to be full of water.
So if you put the
water in the top,
then gravity will
kind of do this thing,
you can see it's on an angle.
So the gravity will come,
it'll just go straight
out the bottom, and
then this whole top part
will be full of air.
That's not helpful.
So we can use gravity
to help us here.
If you put the
water in the bottom,
it'll fill up the
whole condenser
and then go out the top.
And this could be, possibly,
the most important thing
I will tell you today.
This little metal piece is
very important to the success
of your lab.
Does anyone know what this does?
So this piece goes when
you attach your tubing
from your waterlines,
you want to have
one of these little metal guys.
And it'll wrap around your
tubing and your glassware,
and then it'll clip
together to secure
your glassware to your tubing.
And this is important because
once you turn the water on,
the water is at a pretty
decently high pressure.
And if you are not
paying attention,
the tubing does not stay
on these little adapters
very well.
Your tubing will pop
off, and then you
have a faucet of water
coming through a rubber hose.
I don't know if you've ever seen
those like wild inflatable tube
bend, yeah, like that's what's
going to happen in your hood.
And so your lab partner
will be upset with you.
You'll be upset put yourself and
everything will get very wet.
And there are no
drains in the hoods,
so it's a big mess to clean up.
So before you turn
your water on,
make sure that all of
your tubing is clamped.
It's my public service
announcement for the lab.
And your TAs, I'm sure,
will also be checking this
very carefully.
They know what happens.
So then, we have our
condenser, and then we
will have this piece here.
And you can see that there's
another spout out here.
And this connects
to your vacuum line.
So you know those manifolds
that you used with the nitrogen
lines in the ferrozine lab?
Yeah, so one end is connected
to the nitrogen lines
and the other end is
connected to a vacuum pump.
So you're going to use the
vacuum side of those this time.
And so there's a
pressure gauge on there
that will tell you what the
pressure is once you turn
the vacuum on in the system.
It's a digital one, so
you can just read it.
It gives you the
output value in torr.
And we're going to get this
down to close to one torr
or below for this
particular experiment.
So you will make sure that your
vacuum line is connected here.
You'll turn your vacuum on.
And then if we're
going to make sure
this whole system
is under vacuum
and you want to be able to
collect different fractions
so your things will boil
at different temperatures,
so you can't be
swapping your collection
vessel in and out if your
whole system is under vacuum.
So we use what's
called a cow adapter.
So this is a cow thing because
it looks like some cow udders.
And you can attach
four different flasks
to the bottom of it.
And the ones that
you'll see in lab
will have a little spout here.
And so you can see which
flask your spout is pointing
towards when you are using it.
So if you want,
you can rotate this
so that you collect
your different fractions
in different files or
in different flasks.
And you want to make sure
that when you do all of this
that all of your joints are
nice and tightly clamped.
So you want to put Keck clips,
these little yellow guys,
on all of the joints that
you attach to each other.
And then you're going
to use vacuum grease,
and your TAs will show
you how to do that.
You just need a
little bit of grease,
but you want to make sure that
the grease is there to provide
a good seal and so
that you can undo
your glassware after
you've put it under vacuum.
So that is the case.
And then the last thing that you
need to know is the ice bath.
So once you have
heated up your mixture,
you've re-condensed your vapor,
and you're collecting hopefully
another liquid
over here, we have
this under a reduced
pressure, which
means that the boiling
point has now been lowered.
So you don't want
what you've already
collected as pure
product to re-vaporize
and go back into your system.
And you don't want these
to kind of evaporate
and then re-condense
into each other
and contaminate the
fractions that you've
worked so hard to collect.
So you're going to have to
kind of engineer your ice bath
to only cool one flask
at a time, especially
the limonene fraction.
That one tends to
be very volatile.
So your TAs, again,
will tell you
about this when you
get to lab, but you
want to make sure that you
are cooling your fractions
but not cooling too many of them
so that you don't get spillage
into different vessels.
And so that will
be how you collect
your limonene and your carvone.
And hopefully, you should
be able to separate
both of those components from
your essential oil mixture
that you're given.
So some of you guys will
start with the carraway oil,
some of you will start
with the spearmint oil,
and then you will both end
up with limonene and carvone.
It will just depend on
which isomer of the carvone
that you have.
So when we were doing this,
if we know the boiling point
of the limonene and the
carvone at room temperature,
then we need to be
able to figure out
what the boiling point is
going to be under a vacuum.
So you can use what's
called a nomograph.
And there's one of these
in your lab manual,
and I've reprinted it here
just to give an example of how
you use one of these.
And so the way that you
can use this to calculate
your corrected boiling
point at lower pressure
is to figure out what
the pressure is that you
are doing your experiment at.
So you can read, like I
said, the pressure off
of the pressure gauges
in your vacuum lines.
And let's say, for example, that
you have gotten your experiment
down to about one torr.
So you put it out there.
And then that this is your
boiling point at 760 torr,
which is atmospheric pressure.
You know that the boiling point
of whatever you're starting
with is a little bit over 300.
Then you put a point there.
And then you draw
a straight line
through those points that
intersects the observed
boiling point line.
Ta-da!
And then you can find out
that your boiling point
at reduced pressure would be
somewhere around 120 degrees.
So you can see that by
reducing the pressure down
by significantly, that we
can also significantly reduce
the boiling point so we don't
have to heat it up as much.
And we can reasonably get to
these temperatures in the lab.
Any questions about
how to use that?
It's pretty straightforward.
So you can use that to predict
the temperatures that you will
collect your limonene and
your carvone fractions
so you know when to be
looking on your thermometer
to switch your fractions
and when you should
be collecting which ones.
And it'll help you identify
what you've collected.
So that is all of
day one of the lab.
If we made it through day
one of the four day lab.
And so then how will
we know if it worked?
Smell it.
So yeah, so part of the way
that you can tell is you
can smell it.
Waft it gently, don't
ever stick your nose-- so
whenever you're
trying to smell these,
even though that these are
chemicals that people eat,
be gentle.
You guys know and
your TAs can show you
if you're unsure, but don't
ever stick your nose straight
into a vial of any chemical.
So yeah, we can check by smell.
And there are a whole
host of other ways
that we are going to tell
whether you successfully
separated your two
components of your mixture.
And I will leave you
with that, and we
will talk about it on Thursday
all of the different ways
you can determine your success.
Are there any questions about
anything from essential oils
today?
Anything else?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Do we make the
essential oil in the labs?
No.
We have already gotten
it from the plant,
so you don't have to do the
steam distillation part.
We will hand you the oil, and
then you will just separate it
into its components.
All right.
See you on Thursday.